2 de febrero de 2013 para françois este
día tiene el sabor de la Victoria tras
haber respondido favorablemente a la
petición de ayuda del presidente
maliense traoré las tropas francesas son
recibidas en triunfo en tombuctú
qué quiere decirle a françois
es un héroe nacional quiero decirle
gracias
agradecimientos por haber detenido El
Avance de los grupos yihadistas y
separatistas que corrían hacia la
capital bamako el primero de agosto de
2014 París anunció la creación de la
fuerza abarcan en burkina faso Mali
mauritania níger y Chad sus objetivos
luchar contra los grupos terroristas y
ayudar a los ejércitos locales a
estructurarse en el momento álgido de la
operación el continente francés alcanzó
los 5.100 soldados encargados de vigilar
una zona de varios millones de
kilómetros cuadrados pero esta fuerza no
fue capaz de frenar la creciente
inseguridad ni de reforzar
significativamente los ejércitos locales
y la tarea de las tropas francesas se
vio obstaculizada por la inestabilidad
política en maliburquinafazo y chat los
golpes de estado o la fuerte transición
cambian la situación lo que empuja a
París a reducir su presencia en la
región en febrero el ejército francés se
retiró de Mali no podemos asegurar zonas
que vuelven a caer en la desorganización
social porque los estados deciden no
asumir sus responsabilidades ante el
aumento del sentimiento anti francés
experimentado en particular por la
creciente influencia de Rusia en el
sahel a través del grupo paramilitar
Wagner París cerró oficialmente barcan
Este miércoles con el fin de otra
operación Tacuba que hasta el pasado mes
de julio reunió a las fuerzas de varios
estados europeos y sagelinos los cerca
de 3000 soldados franceses A un
desplegados en níger Chad y burkina faso
se encuentran un poco más aislados